hello welcome back to murder mystery
mood everybody
um we haven't done one of these since
december so we skipped a month sorry
about that uh
but we're back and the first thing that
we do on murder mystery mood is make a
drink
i like to try to keep these drinks a
little bit simple so today we're making
a white
russian it only has three ingredients
well four of you include ice
get yourself some vodka some coffee
liqueur we're using kahlua
some heavy cream or if you are
plant-based i'm using an
almond creamer an almond milk creamer
and it's really good so
don't knock it till you try white
russian is yeah you never had one
no you ever watched big lebowski yeah
all right well
i'm new to drinking so i don't really
that's true oh that's cute yeah
all right what you're gonna do is fill
your glass up all the way with ice
you're gonna put
five parts of vodka three parts cream
and two parts coffee liqueur you can mix
these up a little bit
i do i kind of eyeball it but in the
beginning just keep that in mind those
kind of ratios in mind and it looks
really cool if you don't stir it but
it's not going to taste good so
just admire the way it looks at first
and then stir it make sure you stir it
really good
and then it's uh it's a nice little
coffee drink it'll get you pretty jazzed
oh my god nikki you have a heavy hand
yeah you're welcome when she poured it i
was like so the drink is just
ice and entirely vodka i saw her pouring
it
it's a white russian yeah we got a white
[ __ ] american
russian right we don't have these kind
of uh tolerance that they do
in russia in russia i'm a quarter
russian so i can
appropriate that i don't have any
russian
[Laughter]
i haven't had sex with a russian guy yet
i'm interested anyways thank you we're
talking about murder well
we actually are talking about two white
russians
um in fact i picked this because it's
you know it's valentine's day
and i wanted to get a story about a
couple
and what better than a russian
cannibal couple oh my god
they cannibalize together yes not each
other
well i mean well sometimes
a little you know what i mean
well i don't know if they do that
actually they didn't disclose any
information about their sex life i would
have
divulged into it but um yeah so
these headlines came out a few years
back in 2017
the times magazine here in the u.s
had the headline russian cannibal couple
may have eaten
30 people what 30 yeah 30 years i mean
the russians go
hard yeah you know what i mean cold they
need warmth
a lot of iron i don't know i've never
been there but swimming ice with polar
bears like russians are insane
they play chess you know that's wild
[ __ ] i watch queen's gambit
um and the russian uh title the russian
headlines said selfies with human
remains
oh yeah so this story all started
when a group of construction workers
they were you know working on their
new buildings or whatever they're
working on whatever
russians work on yeah whatever russian
construction workers work on
a mosque what are they called oh moscow
no moscow is what i'm thinking of never
mind
there's like a russian temple out of
here they were building moscow one of
those like
the american educational swirling very
sad yeah
anyway um so a group of construction
workers were working and as they were
walking down a road
they stumbled across a cell phone so
being all curious and bored they
decided to scroll through the pictures
wait so it didn't have a lock on it
no no so they wanted someone to find it
i don't know
but yeah who doesn't put a password
everyone has a password on their phone
well this was also i think
kind of an older phone like not a nokia
brick phone but like
around that era oh you know like an
earlier smartphone
yeah like one that has cameras early
2000s yeah like i don't know if it was a
smartphone if it was
sorry razor oh by the way just to
preface this story
i read so many articles and watched so
many videos and they all had really
conflicting details
um the same baseline story but just like
the order of events and like the uh
details were a little so
it might be off on a little bit did a
lot of like junk news
media report on it and then like some of
them kind of made up their own details
or like
yes that and like daily mail said one
thing and then this one
did cover it yeah yeah yeah exactly
daily mail is our favorite job
yeah well and then there's also a
conspiracy at the end which i'll get to
okay but
um yeah so the details just bear with me
i'm gonna try to recite it as best i can
but
anyway so they find this cell phone
right and they start looking through the
pictures because they're like
what kind of people own this phone so
they
at first see like just normal photos but
then
they stumble across uh some photos of a
guy a young gentleman
with dismembered body parts in the
background
and then in his mouth um just tim posing
with a bunch of
various human body parts
so they get freaked out they turn the
phone into authorities immediately
the authorities are like what the [ __ ]
they find out they take out the sim card
and they find out it belongs to a man
named dimitri
and literally everybody yeah yeah a
russian man his name is demetrius either
dimitri or igor
yeah the vladimir and very little um
vowels yeah it's just dm there's a lot
of consonants
why yeah they're very efficient people
when it comes to spelling like just
take out the nonsense yeah so they bring
him in and they're like
uh yo we found your phone here you go
buddy what's going on here and um
and oh and they brought his wife in too
because she was also in the pictures
so his wife's name natalia of course um
rocky and bullwinkle yeah yeah yeah so
uh natalia comes in too and um
it's it varies on who said this but
basically
they were like whoa weird
how convincing where the police like oh
you're surprised too we did not react
like how you would think
um so dimitri is like oh yeah i forgot
so i was walking home and i found a dead
body
in a forest and i started playing with
it so i brought it home
and i just took pictures with it because
it's funny
whoa and the way i didn't even say that
they were prosthetics at least i would
say movie problems
yeah nah he said that and then the wife
was like
i had no idea whoa and so then she's in
the photo
yeah yeah so then they get um a warrant
to go search
the premises right and it gets weirder
oh first let me show you let me show you
a picture of
what they look like because um
yeah you just never know who's like a
murderous cannibal
yeah i want to put a face to these names
yeah same
okay so let's actually shoot i'm only
seeing italian rocky blue winkle
let's see here hold on oh goodness yeah
i wonder if daley might have got those
photos from the phone
cause they got some [ __ ] crazy ass
photos okay so
these were like the photos that were
circulating online she looks asian
do a lot of russians are asian because
they're kind of close friends that man
looks so rushed your prints are part of
it
they're part of the photos they look
like different ages
they are she's actually seven years
older than him
but um yeah so that's the couple and
a little bit of backstory on them dmitry
was orphaned by his biological mother
at um when he was very young and
then he was adopted by a couple when he
was around two
and the mom of the adopted couple passed
away
and the dad got really like aggressive
and he just didn't know how to cope with
the mom's death i guess i don't know
but he ended up kicking dimitri out of
the house at 15.
and dimitri didn't know what to do he
was homeless he didn't have a job he
didn't so he ended up like
robbing and stealing cars and stuff and
so he got he went he was in and out of
prison
a lot um and he was trying to get his
feet back on the ground so when he was
like
16 17 he got a job as a construction
worker
so that's where he was at and then um
natalia she
um had a kind of a normal upbringing she
was raised by her mom and her grandma
and then
um she ended up she wanted to be a
doctor all her life
and so she ended up becoming a nurse she
was in medical school training and she
got a job as a nurse at
uh at a military academy so she was
there doing her thing
and then she got married to one of the
doctors there
and shortly after they had a kid he
passed away
and husband yeah the husband yeah not
the kid the husband
where was murdered i don't
know well anyway she was very distraught
about it so i think he just
passed away because she could not cope
so she started drinking like
crazy um she just drank all day
she ended up losing her job because she
couldn't quit her drinking habit
and dimitri um during this time was like
trying to establish himself right so he
had a construction worker job
but his peers just thought he was kind
of weird like a lot of people that knew
him were like
yeah he's just got a weird sense of
humor and like he doesn't really
know how to socialize very well he talks
to strange people
he likes to go hang out at the local bar
and just like talk to random people so
he ends up
meeting natalya at a local bar one day
and because
he's so much younger than her um she
ends up kind of taking
him under her wing um as like almost
like a maternal figure
and uh seven years apart yeah but he's a
teenager at this time
i mean like 18 years old oh i see him
yeah and so
they start dating they move in together
immediately like almost immediately
pretty weird but huge red flags all
across from all across the board but
it's like they both have their traumatic
pasts and issues and so they kind of
come together and
they're like oh we can share our hurt
together well she never stops drinking
like this
through the whole thing she's drinking
but they end up both living on this um
military academy base i don't know how
they end up living there
it's very wasn't she going for nursing
oh yeah
cool that's right
[Laughter]
is paying attention yeah thank you
listen i'm drinking white russians yeah
the vodka and the clue is getting to you
exactly they were drinking white white
russians also
yeah natalia was probably drinking white
russians without the cream or kahlua
it's just blood yeah of russian actual
white russian potatoes
what happened to her kid during this
time um that's very unclear
so yeah but anyway he ends up going
somewhere else like he's not in her
custody
so anyway um they get together and
um they get caught with this phone
situation 20 years later oh
they've been together for a long time
yeah wow
yeah they developed a deep love you find
that kind of freak you don't
just wait you don't let them go you know
you find
someone who has a weird that matches
your weird yeah
and you hang on to them right love your
life i'm holding out for one so she was
42 and he was 35 by the time they find
this phone
and the authorities after questioning
them and being like wow
these people are very questionable
we're going to go investigate their home
so they go and investigate the home the
home
is a filthy disgusting mess like
the messiest that you can think of
that's what their home looks like they
look it like
looks like a hoarder's house there's
just stuff
everywhere and in the home
they find pretty questionable items um
one they find a jar
okay in the refrigerator they find
various meats
of unknown sources they find there's a
chicken
like a raw chicken just out like in the
in the fridge
um they find a jar of
pickled human remains whoa what remains
yeah like um i'll show you a picture
okay let me show you a picture
sure want to see a picture but you want
to see a picture i want to see a picture
oh it's kind of blurred oh okay it's
blurred but what is it i can't
that's the oh that's whack i want like
intestines and
yeah it's like what's all those balls oh
is that a face
yeah oh my goodness wait turn it around
yeah so is that a bunch of oranges with
a human head yes so they find this
picture
they find a stack of pictures it's not
it's a human head
i gotta find the uncensored ones ain't
uh they're
uh yeah it's a human head so wait let me
just explain where this picture came
from
so the investigators opened a drawer
they found a stack of pictures
they seemed pretty normal at first
there's like people hanging out and then
just a head with oranges around it on us
on a platter on a serving platter that
photo this is the photo they found
like a clown well because there's a
lemon for the nose
and there's olives in the eye sockets oh
my
god yeah i did it
it didn't look like a human head like it
because of how they
put the food inside of it like rotten
skin um
yeah the only thing that you could tell
it was a human head is it's like it is
the shape of a human head and
the parts are in the right place but
yeah they put like um they made it look
like very decorative and
you know they plated it that's nice and
on the back of the photo it was dated
december 28
1999. so they think that it might have
been
a christmas meal yeah and they found
this photo in
my 2017. i am so disgusted right now
they had been doing this for decades oh
damn
um so they find this stack of photos um
there's
plenty more of those there's decapitated
heads
there's uh scalps um just like they
would
scalp the female victim's head
and just it would be it looked like a
wig it looked like a wig
in fact they found wigs quote-unquote
all over the house
and at first they thought they were just
like using them to like
be in disguise and lure victims in but
it turns out they
might have just scalped them off of i'm
actually really surprised that you were
able to look at these
out of all people like people it should
not be you yeah
yeah i will i you blurt so much that i'm
like i need to
know like to me it doesn't look like
anything yet so
i just wanted to know and it didn't look
bloody so i was like okay
i just want to see because it's so
disturbing like you hear about this in
like
movies and stuff but i just wouldn't
think
people actually do this you know damn
and then get away with it for so long
yeah well that was like the most
boggling thing to authorities is how
they were able to do it for so long
how many people like just go missing in
russia to where there's just all these
victims to and then you know like did
their police suck ass or what like
there's
all these dead people this was
unprecedented like people
this was had never happened before yeah
but um
it's usually like people they don't
bother
looking or s or people don't report it
when it's like homeless people
or prostitutes and stuff yeah so i don't
know if that's how it started but
towards the end they're like the remains
that they found belonged to the their
latest victim
who was a waitress that they had met off
of a dating site
so they would actually go on dating
sites looking for
their victims um but posing as like a
couple that maybe wants a third person
or whatever
and um they would give them
a sedative what's it called they would
give them a sedative
called hold on one second corvolol
is a tranquilizer called corvolol and
then once their victim was passed out
they would scalp them alive whoa and
then
dismember them whoa yeah and then store
their remains in the fridge freezer and
cellar so we wouldn't even kill them
that's messed up yeah oh another another
photo
in the stack was a man's decapitated
head with a hand
his own hand in his mouth oh my goodness
um they found a bunch of
cell phones like the same kind of cell
phone that they the construction workers
found
really they found a bunch of those cell
phones you couldn't put passwords on
this
all right well those were dead i guess i
don't know
oh wait no back then the phones didn't
really have passwords no but they found
it in 2017.
yeah i don't know if the phones were
smartphones though i don't know
i don't know very odd um but then
yeah they found 19 bits of flayed human
skin
uh and they found a video titled
video lessons for cannibals wow oh
they're trying to educate that's really
nice yeah
we should appreciate our educators it's
like a cooking tutorial but like where
do you go to find that i'm a little
curious about these flayed pieces of
skin like were they trying to make
chicharron
they were experimenting with different
dishes they got really skilled in fact
um
at one point you said they got really
good on it they got very skilled like
natalia was trying
there there were rumors that she had
been trying to find a job as a chef
and that um she actually would sell pies
to local bakeries
and she said she could source her own
meat oh no meat pies that's like sweeney
todd yeah she's when he's hot at them
yeah i think i remember hearing about
that part she was the latest
meat yeah she was very adamant that she
could source her own meat she didn't
and the cafes would get kind of creeped
out and they were like
no so there was also rumors that they
gave it to the kitchen at the military
academy
a couple times like served can meet um
and there's a theory that they were
trying to convert other people
into cannibalism because there's like a
theory that if you t once you taste
human flesh you get addicted to it wow
so i wonder if you know
it's human flesh you'll get addicted to
it or if you don't know you'll just be
like what was that i would like some
more of that
yeah all the time everyone's like trying
to try to murder them you know
right i thought there was something in
our dna where
it would like humans would taste
disgusting just like with mating with
your own family members
yeah like there's an aversion to it
because it doesn't support evolution
right well definitely like makes you
sick it could make you deranged
yeah like mad cow disease yeah the wrong
parts you know
yes are there any parts that are the
right part
of like the brain or something like if
you eat it you you will get very very
sick
but other parts no yeah so maybe if you
watch the cooking tutorial
you'll know like what parts hey guys
welcome back to my channel right
julia child by the way tune in to next
week's big mood episode we're gonna have
a cooking
show yeah it wasn't our own meat
apparently it was about like how to
get the right fats off of your victim
and
like what parts were the most edible
crazy but fat like i know i kind of feel
like puking right now
but fat looks like uh piles of corn put
together
does it yeah oh that makes sense because
i've seen like i've seen photos of when
people like get
um their legs sliced open i kind of want
to puke right now
do you need to go no i'm gonna hold it
trying to hold it together but okay
this is really graphic okay we'll try to
get away from the
more graphic part of it um so
yes wants to know but my stomach can't
take it
do you they even found a picture wait
can i show you this picture
i'm just gonna exempt myself from the
photos
yeah i'm too nosy to not look wow
they're alive yeah this is a photo of
two decapitated feet on a platter those
are fresh freshly decapitated
blood everywhere well they gotta eat it
they are so white there's not a single
dash of seasoning in there look how
white all the vegetables that's true it
looks very bland
just looks like awesome it does look
like the spice trade didn't make its way
up into russia okay
and i think you need to be considerate
maybe they used a really good freezing
system
too i really would think they would cook
it more those will not look like
diseased
legs i know or feet i mean maybe yeah
maybe that's
very fragile right away yeah that's why
they put vegetables all around well
i would assume you know like when you're
gonna put it in an oven like you put the
vegetables in there you put the
seasoning and then you put it in the
oven i don't know i didn't watch the
video
on the the cooking tutorial but yeah
they're two
decapitated feet on a platter sort of my
peripheral and i'm
okay they just look like regular feet
yeah platter like
literally nothing they didn't deceased
about it change it no blood or anything
oh my god i saw your knee and it freaked
me out a little bit because everything
else is black right here and i was like
what's that skin
it's quarantined that means you guys
should work on your mental health
because we got nothing else to do
and you people need someone to talk to
all the time and that's why
we have talkspace uh talkspace is an app
where you can talk to real licensed
therapists
uh via text messaging them or voice
messaging them or even video and then
you can also have in video
phone face-to-face uh talks also
you can communicate with them 24 7 and
they will se or they will
check their phones and message you back
personally i use this before because
you know i feel like it's better this
way instead of just saving everything
for
one day a week this way you can message
them whenever you're going through they
get to see the crazy in real time
four in the morning to help you yeah um
therapy can really help you shift your
perspective and you can find the tools
to cope in difficult times
and talk space can be a guiding light
it's also very affordable talk space is
a fraction of the cost of in-person
therapy
instead of waiting for an appointment
you can send unlimited messages 24
7 and they will engage with you five
days a week
talk space has thousands of licensed
therapists with years of experience in
over 40 specialties including depression
anxiety substance abuse trauma anger
management relationship issues
food and eating and so much more it's
also very secure and private
uh and they use the latest end-to-end
bank grade encryption technology to
store client information
the therapist that i use gave me
practical guidance that really changed
my life for the better
i'm so glad that i found talkspace and
uh i i'm so glad that i
have someone to listen or message or
dump my brain out whenever i need to
instead of just us every single time
yeah i'm sure you guys thank you
thank you yeah uh jess has gotten
thousands of crying messages at four in
the
morning
i ate another burrito
as a listener of this podcast you'll get
a hundred doll hairs off your first
month with talks
a huge discount that's a lot of doll
hairs
to match the license therapy today to
match with a licensed therapist today go
to talkspice.com and download the app
make sure to use the code mood to get a
hundred dollar hairs off your first
month and show your support for the show
that's mood that's code mood and
talkspace.com
fix your brain sweetheart oh bless your
heart that's it
you know what i love jess what people
have clean butts
do you like clean butter i love clean
buttholes well i've got something for
you
let's clean all the buttholes in the
world jess our sponsor hello tushy
would like to help you keep your
butthole clean now the brand new hello
tushie 3.0 modern bidet attachment is
here
to level the playing field i love it
because it's not it doesn't have to be
plugged into
the outlet yeah i know if it's because
uh i've seen some people that have
bidets in their bathrooms that have a
long cord that goes all the way to the
hey stop stop tweeting me
um next time i prefer to have a
bidet attachment sorry that doesn't have
to be plugged in that's why hellotushy
is great
it's stylish eco-friendly easy to
install and affordable
the hellotushy 3.0 doesn't just cleanse
your butt with a precise stream of fresh
water
it cleans itself too did you know that
that that's what i always had a question
about i was like is the bidet itself
cleaned
i love a hygienic machine but it does it
cleans itself before and after it's used
with the smart spray automatic
self-cleaning nozzle it's like a cat
it's like a vagina
every hello tushy bidet attachment comes
with a 60-day risk-free guarantee and a
12-month
warranty oh yeah you can't get a better
warranty than that you can repaint your
toilet
and clean your
to get 10 off plus free shipping this is
a special offer for our listeners go to
hellotushy.com
big mood for 10 off hellotushy.com
big mood clean your butthole
um so the police go back to them and
they're like
yeah so about you just like finding a
random
dead body phone
dimitri uh confesses to everything right
away but natalia natalia's like uh yo
like i'm kind of crazy like um
she goes yeah if you look at my record i
checked myself
into a psychiatric ward like 20 years
ago nobody did anything about it
so i'm like i can't remember like i'm
crazy and
the she actually went through another
psychiatric evaluation
and they found her to be completely sane
and then when they looked through
her records how did they find her to be
completely sane
exactly so it's worth parameters here
it's [ __ ]
i don't know if she's i mean if you're
completely sane and you do this then
you're just evil
which means you are kind of more
destructive deserving of the punishment
exempts you from at all being sane
yeah there is like that's just they're
they are mutually exclusive that is not
a sane thing to do
i guess it's the difference between
sadistic is what it is you can be
sane and sadistic i don't think that
those are the same like she knows that
it's wrong but she's doing it
exactly or really crazy people they
don't know what they're doing yeah
they're consistently
doing the things they're doing because
they don't realize that they're they're
wrong
i guess in my mind if you're evil you're
not
sane no it's if you know you're evil or
not
exactly if you know what you're doing is
if you find
it off of torture or things that hurt
other people
you are evil but you can still be saying
like you still carry on your day
like you know where you are at all times
like i'm
in los angeles california i'm married to
this person this is my address like
you're very you're sane you're coherent
you just happen to enjoy you drive
pleasure from killing people it's like i
know
this is wrong i know this hurts people
but i'm gonna do it anyways because
i'm more important what yeah is more
important as opposed to
oh yeah no this is totally normal isn't
it normal for you guys no
yeah you know like yeah it's like that
yeah
insane is like when you are like like uh
my grandma had alzheimer's right and
she just she would eat um cat poop off
the floor
and she didn't see anything weird about
that
that's like you lost your mouth yeah you
lost your mind
whereas like a serial killer or this
type of person doesn't go eat cat poop
off the floor unless they
know exactly that they want to eat that
feces and they derive pleasure from it
that's just so weird to me yeah it's
very weird
so it turns out like when she first went
to a psychiatric ward they declared her
completely sane
as well and it was almost there's like a
theory that she
kind of went there to just show that she
had that on her record
so that maybe in the future she could
plead insanity
um but she wasn't she didn't really like
want to be there or think that she
needed any sort of help or anything she
just kind of wanted to be like yeah look
i'm insane
i sh put this make sure this goes on my
record damn
yeah so they still got to be a nurse
after all that
she's been practicing like as a nurse
well
um i know she lost her job remember so
then she got
yeah so she was a nurse had a normal
life so
we think we think she had a normal life
she was with married to her husband
who was a doctor they had a kid oh so
and then when he died
i forgot that part she started drinking
like crazy she just couldn't freaking
cope
maybe she thought there was nothing left
to live before these people support
themselves
during all of this yeah drunken
cannibalistic well she found dimitri
why did they kill people that's true
true um so uh
basically they were like nah you're
saying but
weirdly like the media calmed down like
after all this evidence came out the
media went
quiet so that was really that was really
odd
um after all of this came to light there
were
interviews with like friends and
neighbors and acquaintances
and they were like all creeped out and
thinking back on some of their
conversations with the couple
and neighbors say that uh the former
nurse natalia
made and sold pies to boost her income
so she boasted to cafe owners that she
could supply her
own meat and and has worked as a chef
even though they couldn't find any
chef history oh my god imagine being one
of the people you ate her pies
what are you doing no well maybe she
sold them but the local cafe owner that
was talking about this said
in 2010 she was very active asked lots
of questions but mainly about where we
buy our meat
and fish and how fresh it is she made it
clear she could supply
meat and i said we only work with
certified suppliers
and she said like she was trying to be a
supplier for that deli yeah not just to
sell the pies but she was like hey i've
got
yeah i want some pots of [ __ ] beef
over here for you
yes he was like we're good
yeah and then the cafe owner also said
for sure these cannibals were looking
for places to sell their meat
it sounded to me like her main motive
was was that she was looking for a job
natalia told me she had experience
working as a chef
but the owner refused to work with her
saying she looked vulgar
quote unquote she never came back he
said an interesting word to use
yeah and then police are investigating
how the couple were allowed to live for
years
in the grounds of a military academy run
by the russian defense ministry
um friends of the couple say demetria
was an even-minded person
and that eating people just didn't sound
like his style
but she could believe that he took a
dead body home and took pictures with it
because he had a weird sense of humor
wow
um yeah she was declared sane despite
going to mental hospital but she got
sent to prison for 10 years
including going to a penal colony which
is like an
island where they basically
like you're doing slave labor oh yeah
interesting
and he got taking license plates he got
12 years in
maximum security present and he uh
got put with like um psychiatric help um
12 year what that's
what are these little short i know
and what's weird is like they redacted
their
confession so at first they confessed to
30 murders
and then they redacted it later like
they took it back
and they said oh actually we didn't kill
as many people as we said we did it was
only that one that you found
and um like we didn't eat them
it's because of the military being
involved that's the that's the
conspiracy theory yeah because we're
trying to cover it up because they did
all this on
military grounds in the military so the
military is like oh
we didn't let this happen right
underneath our nose yeah
and then the murder that they did
confess to which was this
the recent victim um was this waitress
that they had found
on the dating site and um they said the
the reason it happened was because the
waitress
got way too flirty with dimitri and
natalya
got super jealous about that that's it
and so natalya like yelled at dimitri
in a drunken rage to kill her and he
followed orders immediately
because it's like his mama telling him
to like kill and then
dimitri said that after he started
stabbing her
that's when natalya joined in and then
they didn't know what to do with it so
they just dismembered it
the body yeah yeah i mean that doesn't
that doesn't explain the head on the
platter and the feet
yeah yeah so to this day that's still
unexplained and another theory is that
they um aren't they didn't do all this
on their own
that they're part of probably a greater
group of cannibals and they just kind of
took
into the military maybe it doesn't
say but but like basically there's
people were saying
that there's no way that this one couple
could have killed
this many people and i don't know
they were just like it's and gotten away
with it for so long
that there has to be a group that's
helping them cover that has a system
involved that like how did they get away
with it for
so long because they were doing it at
the military base yeah
i wonder if they're like military was
this fort hood jesus um
[Music]
like the like enemies to the state or
something because you know how like they
poison people like the russian
government's just [ __ ] nuts
so i wonder if they're like you know
like the mob has like people to get rid
of bodies to like sink them in the
[ __ ] new york river just like to eat
them so they're like oh we can dispose
of bodies
like state government why would she want
to go out there and like be all
ambitious with their [ __ ] meat pie
business and supplying
maybe she was trying to get rid of
evidence she needs to figure out how to
how to get rid of the meat or to convert
more people into cannibalism that's what
i'm thinking
there's a cannibal club in la is there
excuse you
yeah there's one there's like a website
uh
where like it doesn't really give you
information it doesn't tell you where it
is or whatever it says
it's one of those like application
things apply for it
um how many police apply to that [ __ ] on
a daily basis
yeah it also says like um
please understand that we acquire our
food ethically or something like that
yeah for people that want to die
yeah yeah i've heard of these there's
cannibal cafes and there's a whole like
debate about whether or not it's ethical
because
people will volunteer to sacrifice
themselves and like
donate their bodies to the cafe like a
leg or something
yeah no yeah i'm not gonna lie i am
pretty sure that's illegal though it is
illegal
so but if they just have a website i
don't know what are you gonna say i'm a
little curious
to eat or to donate
if you apply part of their protocol is
like you have to eat it in front of them
or something
mm-hmm i just want to try a small piece
and see what it's like what
like i want to i want to just know like
the texture
i get that curiosity no i do not take it
back i stand by my word
lady what part a finger what do you want
like i was like take a piece of your
thigh or something
literally just a small bite that's all
like
maybe jess's biopsy
i'm like that too and i've tried a lot
of crazy different animal
meats and all that stuff and i know
nikki hates hearing this part but sorry
but i have tried like a lot of different
weird things
and i couldn't get myself to try horse
and that is pretty commenting what about
a dog a dog yeah
i haven't tried dog with i saw it on the
menu
i wouldn't i don't think i could do dog
i couldn't do horse i thought i could do
horse and i couldn't do horse could you
do a moose
probably okay i could probably do horses
are like too friendly
i think yeah like i've tried i've tried
puffins you tried whale
yeah i've tried kangaroo alligator
um like there are certain ones that if
they're too intelligent i just feel like
they should be off limits
like that's how you feel about that
things are so smart oh pigs
yeah they can read you could train them
to read they operate at
the emotional intelligence of a
five-year-old right so they know when
their mom's getting taken away
no more i don't want to hear anymore
they've committed suicide i hear that
but that doesn't
yeah well i am telling you more because
stop eating these smart creatures
i want to be ignorant you want to be
ignorant ignorant
for some reason you telling me that
doesn't change my opinion on eating
that's fine
but it might change some people's
because it changed mine oh well i didn't
like pig to begin with but yeah you
don't even like the taste so obviously
it's easier to be like oh and they're
kind of smart
except for pulled pork i used to like
that but
barbecue sauce is they're so smart
there's something i know
i could never eat octopus i kind of
believe that they are the actual aliens
that are on earth
right and i used to love eating octopus
but now i'm like oh i kind of second
thanks guys
so freaking smart so yummy i never
really eat it i had
uh what are the squids not octopus right
it's different i've had some of that but
yeah i've had live live stuff too oh i
could never eat something
yeah i know i had live lobsters
well it's looking at you being like stop
eating i like it when it looks me in the
eyes i want to see the lights go out no
i'm kidding they're just like crackling
i'm kidding nikki i'm kidding mickey
i'm kidding you're not yeah
like he doesn't have to die for it he
just cuts a little square out a little
biopsy thing
like in the platform yeah you know just
a little spoiler alert
it's not a spoiler happens like the
first 15 years you're spoiling it
it's the first fifty nine you're fine
it's not gonna spoil you're good it
doesn't it doesn't change the storyline
a lot of crazy [ __ ] happens like you
find out right away
isn't that a russian oh yeah no i
thought it was spanish
oh i think it is spanish yeah because
when i saw the trailer i was like you're
right you have to read the subject
i think you know what it is the dubs
like they did dubbed over it in english
and the guy's accent sounds russian
i think it's crazy when when when
couples or two peoples or friends or
whatever
find an equally crazy yeah you know what
i mean like
then you always speculate like was it
one that was more crazy and kind of
manipulated the other like because i
think you know she was so much older
than him
he would do anything that she said yeah
um but he did have the more history
of going in and out of prison and so i
don't know like
would if they hadn't met would
they have done that sometimes it's like
a it's a multiplier
yeah the crazy because it's like a when
you
it's also like people who are kind of
crazy online like when they find other
crazies online and they they start
getting like
tinfoil money because they feel like
someone else is
confirming and validating so it just
confirmation bias it's
exponential growth of crazy right dude
oh sorry go ahead no and it makes sense
for you too because he was young
impressionable he wanted to keep love
makes you do crazy things he wants to
keep her so
yeah i mean they stay together for a
long long time and in fact he got
super depressed in jail and he actually
had a human rights activist trying to
get the wife to be able to see him
because it's it's cruel that he's so
depressed and
yeah he actually part of your punishment
though is yeah isolation
but he like you know people need to feel
love i guess i don't know
um that's what the human rights activist
was going for but he actually passed
away
this uh february of last year what yeah
from sadness
his valentine from a broken heart from a
broken heart or a lack of human iron or
like
i think it's funny or i think it's weird
how it's like what if it was two crazy
people how do you bring that up like hey
have you ever
yeah like joking yeah you think it was
like
they murdered someone and then they
didn't know what to do with the body and
they're like have you ever been curious
or
right or like how do you even get to the
point of murder like how do you talk
yeah
or it's like hey you ever wanted to more
to someone no okay just kidding
yeah they tried to ask them questions
and they wouldn't really give up much
information as to why that's why
they speculate that maybe they're
covering for a larger group
all right let's actually establish some
healthy habits here in 2021 as well
the app noom is for healthy habit weight
loss but also just like
in general setting good habits because
it really gets to the psychology
of why you form good and bad habits so
nume doesn't give you rules but instead
teaches you how to think so you can
accomplish your personal health goals
stick with them long term and get
healthy for good
personally i've used noom because i tend
to grab
snacks and eat when i feel stressed
or anxious and i did not i didn't know
that i just thought i am a snacker
but i'm not really a snacker it's just
um
realizing that it's connected to anxiety
and stress rather than just a random
thing that happens
really helped me stop doing that now i
only eat when i'm hungry
um other examples are like eating better
to feel better
you can get an improved sense of
self-worth more confident in a crowd
sometimes i would do that one at events
i would go straight to
the snack table because i just couldn't
handle talking to people and
it's good to know that so you can fix it
it's based in psychology neum teaches
you why you make the choices you do and
gives you tools to replace your habits
with healthier ones
noom's cognitive behavioral approach
means you're not just improving your
health
you're gaining the knowledge and habits
you need to stay healthy and everyone's
busy that's why
noom doesn't demand much of your time
they only ask for 10 minutes a day
that's nice that's like nothing yeah i
tried to like go through the app longer
than 10 minutes and it was like hey take
a break
we're low maintenance here there's a
science to getting healthier it's called
noom sign up for your trial today at
noomnoom.com
big mood learn how to get healthy with
noom sign up for your trial today at
noomnoom.com
big mood ready to live healthier sign up
for noom today
at noom.com big mood
big mood and speaking of your body
it's also quite important to know where
you you stand with your fertility
because traditionally the guidance with
fertility has been just wait and see
but now we have tools to help us plan
for and track
almost everything in our lives so just
waiting and seeing about fertility just
isn't good enough
that's where modern fertility home
fertility testing comes in
it's the easy and affordable way to test
your fertility hormones at home with a
simple finger prick
mail it in with a prepaid label and
you'll get your personalized results
within 10 days
traditional testing with your doctor can
cost over a thousand dollars but
modern fertility only costs 159 dollars
to get the same
information also if you have an hsa or
fsa
you can use those dollars on modern
fertility you'll get insight into how
many eggs you have hormone levels and
other important fertility factors
the results go deep into what every
hormone means and you
also can talk one-on-one with a
fertility nurse to review your results
and options for next steps i recently
got my
results back what did it say i was
actually quite nervous i sent mine in
but i haven't gotten my results come i
didn't get one
you genuinely you're getting you check
the messages you never check your emails
imagine tiff's results came back like
[ __ ] you're mexican
you're wasting our time i know i'm
expecting mine to come back and say i've
got two eggs left so
you're out of luck they email you back
they're like i'm surprised that finger
prick didn't get you pregnant
yes i actually have my results right
here and so it says
it it tested my tsh which is a thyroid
stimulating
hormone and it gives me the results so
it says like i have a 1.35
apparently the flag is normal and it
ends up giving you like a reference
range and all this other information so
all these different hormones and
thankfully
i'm normal across the board normal for
my age they're very specific
to say that like because i'm 31 now and
uh
so yeah they they do say like normal for
my age
which is okay like i'm good i'm good
with that i'm good with that does that
mean fertile for your age right for my
age it means i'm average
like i'm at where most women at my age
are at wow but yeah getting these
fertility results has really eased my
mind
so i'm really glad that modern fertility
sent me one thank you so much so if you
guys want to get your own right now
modern fertility is offering our
listeners 20
off the test when you go to modern
fertility.com
mood that means your test will cost 139
dollars instead of the hundreds or
thousands it could cost
at a doctor's office get 20 off your
fertility test when you go to
modernfertility.com
mood modernfertility.com mood
but yeah it's weird the timing too
because like uh you guys hear about army
hammer
yes yeah that's why you brought up like
lovers and cannibals
you know the actor yeah social network
social network too i was thinking arm
and hammered the brain yeah
everyone does yeah no not the baking
soda there's someone named arm and
hammer
army
name [ __ ] armies it's some rich white
guy
no he's the son of a oil tycoon or yeah
some sort of titanic he's like
he's trying to be an actor god damn he's
gonna see this episode he's gonna kill
me
no he's he's in he's very attractive
he's very
handsome yeah army hammer this dude you
know armin van buren i'm a braver
but he started started making really
weird comments
handsome okay yeah and it bleeds into
this theory that um
the elites of the world like the people
that have so much money and so much
power that they have an underground
society
they can only get their kicks it makes
sense pedophilia and cannibalism
yeah like what do you do when you have
it all
yeah you start to like power in other
ways i guess i i personally don't feel
like all of the elites are some sort of
weird crazy disgusting
i just feel like there's a percentage of
the population that has mental illness
and that's going to be dispersed
throughout rich and poor
yeah money brings out whatever you
naturally without money because these
poor ass [ __ ] were killing up
and serving up heads on a platter so i
don't think the money has anything to do
with it i think there's just a
percentage of people who are [ __ ]
nuts and when you have money it makes it
easier well the
like army hammer right like so he can he
could uh
talk to these models and stuff and like
say crazier and crazier [ __ ] and it's
like it's almost like well i don't
i don't want to get into a thing like
he's a you know he's right right
rich guy actor like i'm not gonna you
know make a deal out of it you know i'll
just move on but
so i i guess there's you could probably
get away with like more weird [ __ ]
maybe for a little while but someone's
gonna blow the whistle like that
girl did epstein you know had a whole
island and you know all these
if you watch that documentary um the
victims were like yeah we said [ __ ] but
everybody was
didn't was too scared to touch it
because like he owns everything
yeah so i mean imagine in third world
countries where you can just pay off
anything
yeah yeah i mean that does happen
there's a i mean there's a huge sex
trafficking ring mostly with minors
um it's really sad that's the one thing
about like getting old that i'm happy
about like when i'm older
nobody wants to trap me yeah i'm fine
yeah we're already past parts or like
you know yeah so that's a good part of
getting older yeah
yeah yeah that's a good part we're out
of the rape zone
probably not tips like no not really i
mean personally
or on the line yeah their latest victim
she was a 35 year old waitress so we're
not quite out of
out of the line of cannibalism oh geez
yeah i'll just make sure not to go on
any dates with any couples
[Music]
i mean well you know jeffrey dahmer was
well he was
gay but he still yeah that would get me
because i'd be like oh you're gay cool
right i can have my two guy threesome
that's true
they're like yeah you're the dessert
yeah [ __ ]
so she's still alive yeah she's still
alive she's still
serving a sentence oh yeah no she's not
in a mental anything she's in prison
yeah she's in the penal colony maybe
still
i don't know if she's [ __ ] pumping
out license plates i wonder if she ever
craves it like man i can go for a good
thigh right now i wonder if she sucks on
her own like blood
because that's the only way you could i
mean yeah
like cuts other people like she starts
fights or some [ __ ] she complained about
getting bullied in prison because like
her cell mates were like do you miss the
taste of people
what a weird thing like oh look the
people eater
the russian people eater imagine i was
like oh i wish you you wish you can do
this huh
what a weird thing that just goes to
show you can bully people for anything
yeah
yeah that's great and she was like sad
about it she's like stop calling me
people you know russians are so hardcore
that they're not even afraid of the
candle but they're like oh this [ __ ]
stupid-ass cannibal [ __ ] all the other
women in the prison are like oh these
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ]
right you don't scare me she's like the
normal one
yeah they're the psychopaths and it's
just [ __ ] okay he's like oh you just
cannibal
why wait i'm not filipino i'm sorry
you're just a cannibal comrade
you know pathetic i'm russian
[Laughter]
um yeah maybe they're like you ate them
we have actual food yeah like we just
murdered yeah right
i just i just killed her it's gross
how funny is that that the russian
standards
are so crazy that cannibals are like she
still gets bullied
[ __ ] right like i [ __ ] putin what did
you do
[Laughter]
yeah you eat cannibal or you eat people
i eat putin's
i can't stop thinking about the people
who might have eaten her food though
they're like holy [ __ ] i wonder i've
been craving that [ __ ] ever since
i'd be pissed i wonder if that's true
though like where did that come from
that like if you eat human you're gonna
be addicted to it you're gonna crave
like i wonder if that's like i mean
the only evidence we have of that is
anecdotes from
cannibals so like they're just crazy
like i was a normal person
i ate normal food that was tricked you
see
i
no maybe that's why they didn't get her
as a supplier because they're like your
pot pies are tried it and they were like
trash is
[ __ ] briny and it's gaming gross
so salty i just finished watching
hannibal
have you seen the show with the with mad
men in the show no i haven't seen the
show yeah the show's actually really
good
where is it is it streaming uh better
like netflix
okay yeah why are you so many cultures
i have no identity of my own apparently
yeah um but mads mickelson plays
hannibal and he's like this very
extremely cultured intelligent man
and he cooks the human parts like so
beautifully in different dishes it's
actually really cool so while you're on
this human
meat kick right now like i try it now if
i was a tin foil hat person i'd be like
they're trying to brainwash the pup
they're trying to normalize this yeah
they're trying to get people interested
invested curious and look it's working
no she just already has an affinity for
weird [ __ ]
that's true you can't brainwash people
who aren't like willing to be brave
exactly she's got an open mind an open
channel
i just i just want the elites are
getting to you
the what the elites yeah hey hit me up
cannibal elite
like one small bite that's all you know
small only because i am just
driven by curiosity and i have been my
whole entire life
would you eat your own body yes like if
there's a way for me to like
kind of take a little chunk out without
it hurting your boobs yeah yeah like
they go
you just ask them to get the tip of the
tip of the nip yeah
on the inside she won't have a nipple
the inside of the neck it's going to be
something like this like under my arm
here or something like i just want to
try maybe i'll fatty
maybe like oh yeah take your arm fat you
should be like i don't want like but
that's just fat belly i want like meat
yeah you have
you want muscle yeah i want that meat
that we eat right
yeah i don't eat it no i mean like yeah
like you know regular
you know we don't eat animal just fat
yeah you like cooking it down you cook
it down you cook your [ __ ] in it you
cook with lard and i would want it in
like the most like true form like no
like very maybe a little bit of salt and
pepper but no like sauces or anything i
just
because i'm just going to taste the
actual flavor of it exactly i want to
taste the actual flavor and i've been
eating regular meat without things on it
yeah salt and pepper is all you really i
need it at its purest
for beef and i want to know the texture
when you go to the bodies exhibit in
vegas
are you like get hungry
makes me go no no
yeah i don't even know how they're
allowed to have that exhibit it's just
very
it might have been from chinese
dissonance yeah yeah so they all hate
asians
really yeah they're all asian it seems
like
questionable why they're allowed to have
these exhibits of the all these asian
people chopped up
yeah yeah it felt so wrong like that we
paid for that
and then walked through it and i was
like this man i regretted that yeah
or something i don't see it like yeah we
didn't actually pay for it
the company we're gonna waste this yeah
i don't remember my curiosity was
uh dude i felt so killed and this is so
so wrong oh i wanted a shower it would
have been like disneyland for me
but because that's because like i don't
see it as like a
like like a creepy thing i see it as
extreme science educational
dude that's how i usually see it too
like surgery videos and stuff like i
like witnessing a surgery in front of my
eyeballs like i'm like whoa
cool scientific hats on like what is
this ligament here or whatever
but seeing that exhibit i i was trying
to put my science hat on and i just felt
like
wrong yeah they looked they looked like
they didn't volunteer for this weird
yeah it was interesting uh but there's
probably like a lot of
like science behind why this discovery
well i mean just like we've gotten a lot
of scientific discovery and medical
advancements and stuff from
people having to do autopsies and all
kinds of other things with dead bodies
right so i mean i
i'm not against it i guess but it's just
it's weird that it's on display
when i was in the brief time that i was
in college
for the semester i was in college i was
in biomed and
we actually went looked at a live
cadaver like we
they sliced it open like all kinds of
stuff like it was
and i was able to separate it then like
it just didn't
it felt like not a real person it was
like because it's so lightweight
you can tell that there's no soul inside
the body exactly
i noticed that when i did see the body
of my mom i was like
my mom's not even in there anymore it's
not she's not there anymore
you can tell yeah but i wouldn't put her
body on display
you know like yeah i
yeah and put eyelashes on me yeah like
that'd be great
there were eyelashes on the bodies yeah
in the vegas yeah they have fat as well
yeah pubic hair interesting yeah pubes
yeah i'm just thinking about it
yeah it was just it was a lot different
than looking at cadaver it just felt off
it didn't feel sciencey it felt like i
think it's because it was on displaying
it to pay to go look it was almost like
an attraction
which it shouldn't be when you're it's
weird that they're making money off and
they cut it in weird ways
like they would cut it yeah yeah well
like even like straight
i shaved it yeah like shaved it like
there's one display where it like
yeah almost like they made it artistic
yeah like they made it artistic and i'm
like
it is human body it's not science
anymore
yeah it just feels wrong i think it's a
beautiful art
you know up for debate controversial
yeah but yeah anyway that's uh
my love story for valentine's day yes
and how it smells when you cook it
oh you want to know how it smells i know
because i've only smelled formaldehyde
when i looked at it funny story when i
dissected a
pig's fetus when i was in high school
that formaldehyde
smell kind of ruined pork for me for the
longest time because i swore that
whenever i ate ham or something i
smelled that smell
and i couldn't do it i never did the
dissecting a pig fetus thing we got a
frog yeah we got a frog too
um i got frog cows eyeball and pig fetus
all we got was a frog maybe our school
was just broke
we had a frog but i'm pretty sure i was
one of those kids that was like
i think this is wrong i'm not doing it i
don't remember doing it i just remember
i remember either i don't remember where
i did i don't know it wasn't live though
they brought in an already dead yeah
like in et when they were live like
they mean
yeah hopefully i can't do lily let his
free
yeah yeah i'd rather if they were dead
already because i can't
yeah it was pretty even sad even when i
had my snake
i didn't like feeding him love that's
the worst part about having her
well you're not supposed to freedom life
no no no just feeding
so going to the pet shop picking out a
rat getting the rat in the brown bag
and then because the pet shop owner
won't do it then you have to get the
[ __ ] wrap no bag and
smack it on the floor until it dies it's
all twitching and then we have to feed
it
oh
and i'm like this is killing my soul i
could never i couldn't it's natural i'll
never do that no it's not natural for a
human to kill the prey and then give it
to the snake
that is not natural but it's healthy for
them to eat it right yeah
it's natural for the not to be a pet
would you rather the snake
eat the mouse alive where the mouse is
like slowly dying screaming no i would
have it i wouldn't deal with no no i'm
just saying like in nature it's gonna
happen either way you know what i have a
cat and a nature it eats it alive but
in real life i give it a can of cat food
yeah
snakes don't have that i'm never gonna
kill a mouse for my cat because i'm very
like one animal doesn't deserve to live
more just because he's fluffier and
cuter
for sure but it can live in the wild why
would they make it a domestic pet
because people like you wanna you know
snake people
be weird snakes i mean let's be honest
people are weird we are
yeah yeah we are i think that's true
that's true
you're both the year of the snake yeah
that's true i'm here with the tigers so
that's why i have so many cats see
that makes sense little baby predators i
didn't have to kill the mouse
or the rat i just picked it out and then
they went to the back and slammed they
didn't do that for us gina
oh you went to the wrong pet store you
didn't tell me i should have told you
where to go
you know you weren't a very good mom see
i had you had us have pixel for like two
years you never visited her you didn't
tell us where to get the rat
yeah that's true that's true that's true
so on that note um we're gonna go um but
i hope you enjoyed this episode of
murder mystery move i'm looking up these
photos
i feel so go nuts yeah i feel really
disgusting right now that's a natural
reaction i feel
this is a sane reaction like my body's
weak
yes i know maybe we could pick a less
gruesome one next time i just wanted you
to have a romantic
um i don't feel romantic i don't feel
sexy
next time i'll pick a stalker or
something yes give us like a you
type of you know that show on netflix no
i mean i totally saw the romantic
element where like in prison he was
he was missing her i was missing her
even at a human rights activist like
this he loves his wife
romantic only speaking that kind of
stuff they said they have
had a really deep connection that they
would never be with anyone else
deep in someone else's guts and lungs
say it unites people
i think it's people it's funny like who
the [ __ ] is this human rights activist
and are you sure you're doing your job
right
right like why aren't you sticking up
for the people they ate
like yeah they got murdered and eaten
but this guy's depressed it's like pita
where like they'll
um stick up for animals but they'll also
kill animals because
we'd rather have animals dead than
suffering exactly that's what they do
i do like what you said though like find
someone who matches your weird that's
cute
yeah yeah that is cute i do not uh
recommend
eating people that too yeah if that's
your weird
check yourself in we are yucking that
yum we are going to yuck that yum
hard big big time big heart if anyone is
out there that's willing to let me try a
piece or a thigh
gina no this is not an advertisement
i'll see you next week thanks for tuning
in
bye